shock on fire
um
officials in Texas release dramatic body
and dash camera video of an
officer-involved shooting after a
suspect rests his weapon on the hood of
a police squad car to aim at officers
31 41.
shots fired
on May 6th a 9-1-1 call came in to San
Antonio dispatch from a woman reporting
her mother's neighbor was pointing a
weapon at her 911 this is Michelle
denier police fire or EMS uh police
what's going on
um it's my mother's address I pulled up
to her house me and my niece and one of
her neighbors he was standing outside
when we pulled up and he started
pointing at us and he like went into his
house and got this big gun he pointed it
at us and we had to like reverse out of
the street because what kind of gun was
it pointing it it was like a long rifle
body camera video shows San Antonio
police officers meeting up with the
caller to assess the situation
and we literally just pulled up to the
curb in front of my mom's house like we
always do he saw us and he started like
yeah you know is he a skinny boy like
yes shirtless long hair like right here
the woman tells officers the suspect
pointed the weapon at her and he comes
out with this long
gun this black and brown gun and he was
just like waving it around and then he
pointed about it officers identify the
suspect with the weapon as 22 year old
Brian spangert body camera video then
shows them approaching Spenger's home
can be heard yelling at officers from
the backyard
at this point officers back off
believing it to be a mental health
situation they contact the San Antonio
Police Department mental health unit at
the same time a second 9-1-1 call comes
in saying spangert is outside naked with
a weapon
right now
officers can then be heard calling for
spenger to put down the weapon
put the rifle down come over here
walk over here please to the sound of my
voice it's all right we're here to help
you out it's okay
okay we're here for you
my name's Tim
walk over here
and I'll talk to you it's all right
during this time spangert goes in and
out of his house multiple times
sometimes carrying the weapon officers
then create a perimeter around spangert
as he shouts incoherently
on us
a San Antonio police department
supervisor fired at spangered and hit
him in the arm he did not turn on his
body cameras so there's no video from
his perspective separate officer body
camera video shows the moments leading
up to the shooting and the police
response that follows
foreign
after the shooting officers made a
tourniquet for spangert he was taken to
the hospital later for treatment
officials recovered Springer's weapon on
the scene and determined it was damaged
and could not fire spangert now faces
two counts of deadly conduct and
aggravated assault on a peace officer
the shooting is still under
investigation reporting for long crime
Network I'm Sierra Gillespie